des banderoles installées à fort de
france au quartier sainte-thérèse devant
les crèches timoun faut y aller madinina
crèche de sculptures qui accueille une
quarantaine d'enfants
cela fait deux jours que le personnel
est en grève ils réclament la tenue
d'élections en scène l'entreprise pour
la cdmt ces deux entités sont gérés par
le même j'ai eu la même directrice au
total de crèches et les gia cela fait 19
employés
c'est suffisant pour organiser des
élections nous sommes là le 19 salariés
ce qui fait que l'élection des délégués
du personnel est tout à fait faisable
l'employeur le reconnaît l'employeur a
la volonté de le faire mais ils ont les
difficultés je vais dire leur
compréhension des implications parce
qu'ils n'ont pas la maîtrise du doigt
c'est tout simple à partir du moment
qu'on maîtrise pas un sujet il est
difficile de trouver les solutions
et voilà où nous en sommes actuellement
pour la directrice de ces deux crèches
privées chacune de ces structures ne
dépasse pas en salariés donc impossible
d'organiser des élections mais des
solutions sont à l'étude et la
directrice dit vouloir respecter le
droit on veut pas seul ce la vie voilà
comme je vous ai dit l'inspection du
travail
notre avocat donc au niveau donc de l'
organisation sappros quand même du temps
de lire des textes comprendre qu'on a
voulu ce vraiment ce s'entourer de
personnes qui nous guide et qui nous
permettent de mettre en place ou mieux
est ce qu'il faudrait si effectivement
vous pouvez mettre en place des actions
pour les deux ce que tu vas nous faire
on va là les salariés des deux crèches
restent donc mobilisés en espérant que
le droit s'appliquera au sein de leur
entreprise